[Musique]
nous sommes le 9 août 2016 il est
exactement midi sur l'île de jersey je
fais face à la mer et je marche jusqu'au
bout de la digue
j'ai peur un peu comme maintenant je
m'apprête à sauter à l'eau pour tenter
de devenir la première personne âgée de
l'île de jersey jusqu'à saint-malo 70 km
de nage répartis sur quatre jours
c'est une pure folie dans l'eau je peux
pas écouter de musique je peux pas
parler avec mes amis et je dois
absolument occuper mon esprit pour ne
pas douter
alors je me remémore toutes les
aventures qui m'ont amené à sauter à
l'eau l'ascension d'une montagne dans
l'himalaya à 6153 mètres d'altitude là
haut
seul je comprends que tout est possible
la seule personne qui peut me stopper
c'est moi et personne d'autre
à cause de la houle je bois souvent la
tasse et je tends mon estomac qui se
remplit d'eau de mer et le sel qui fait
mal et je découvre quelque chose
d'incroyable c'est qu'on peut avoir le
mal de mer en nageant c'est terrible je
passe mon temps à vomir ouais c'est
comme ça mais c'est moi qui ai décidé
alors je continue à nager
je me revois l'année de mon premier
marathon
une fois que j'avais terminé cette
course je comprends que je peux aller
beaucoup plus loin
alors je cours 100 km là encore je
comprends que les seules frontières
les seules limites qui existe réellement
elles sont là dans nos têtes
le bateau comme cris n'a julien âge
alors jeune âge mais je peux pas mon but
j'ai enfin je suis obligé de penser à
paul watson qui est parrain de
l'aventuré
c'est un homme qui est réputé pour ses
actions coup de poing il a sauvé des
milliers de baleines et celle honte le
fondateur de sea shepherd et il dit
quelque chose qui m'a marqué si les
océans meurent nous mourrons
saviez vous que chaque seconde
960 kg de déchets se déversent dans les
océans
neuf cent soixante neuf cent soixante
neuf cent soixante ça se passe
maintenant cette traversée à la nage
celle aventure swim foshan
c'est pas qu'un défi sportif pour moi
c'est un moyen de crier haut et fort
engagez-vous dans la protection de
l'environnement passer à l'action
jetez vous à l'eau le dernier jour je
devais nager 25 kilomètres à cause de
différentes raisons j'avais pris du
retard et il ya quelque chose que vous
ne savez pas c'est que je n'avais jamais
nagé plus de 5 km avant donc je vois que
l'équipe commence à stresser et le
dernier jour au moment de sauter à l'eau
je dis à mon équipe je remonterai pas à
bord tant que les pages touché terre
mais moi je m'interdis de doute et je ne
peux pas abandonner je peux pas échoué
nous devons réussir parce que pour moi
cette nage elle est à l'image de la
transition environnementale
on voit pas derrière l'horizon mais on
sait qu'on doit y est impossible
interminable petit pas par petit beau
petit geste pas petit geste c'est
possible alors je continue à nager et un
et deux et trois le 12 août à 20h53 je
peux enfin sentir le sable sous mes
pieds je venais de le faire c'était
incroyable je venais de réaliser un rêve
je dit on parce que c'est un travail
d'équipé avec maxime
florian nils laurent florian on faisait
péter le champagne sur la plage on
embrasse et nos amis il y avait des
inconnus qui venaient faire des selles
fille j'ai embrassé ma petite maman le
lendemain
ouest france publiait julien moreau un
éco aventurier heureux je venais de
réaliser mon rêve
j'étais devenu la première personne à
avoir nagé de jersey à saint malo
c'était incroyable mais à l'intérieur de
moi je suis très en colère très en
colère parce que je comprends que j'ai
beau avoir fait ça ça changera pas qui
je suis ça changera pas ma famille et
encore moins mon histoire personnelle
le 9 décembre 1993 j'ai 4 ans et ma mère
m'ont mène à l'école et pendant ce temps
là mon père est à la maison et il
s'apprête à faire la plus grande
connerie de sa vie il descend dans le
garage
il prend une corde il se donne la mort
là sur la plage
je suis très énervé parce que je
comprends que depuis gamin je cherche à
transformer cette énergie négative en
quelque chose d'incroyablement positif
incroyablement positif alors aujourd'hui
adultes cherchent à transformer la la
violence en aux violences
l'égoïsme en générosité le rejet social
en créant une communauté
de cet acte de mort je me suis
transformée en protecteur de la vie et
puis en même temps c'était la mort des
rêves parce que nous devions partir
faire un tour du monde à la voile
alors aujourd'hui je mets un point
d'honneur à défendre mes rêves
finalement ce que cherche à faire c'est
stopper ce suicide est planétaire
c'est pour ça que je suis devenu un éco
aventurier parce qu'à travers l'écologie
je cherche à protéger leur vie la vie
sous toutes ses formes et je le fais en
créant des aventures parce que c'est mon
rêve de créer des aventures on n'a pas
tous besoin de vivent des drames pour
passer à l'action
vous avez sûrement quelque chose à
l'intérieur de vous qui peut vous donner
le déclic est passé à l'action
vous savez être aventuriers c'est pas
gravir des montagnes c'est pas courir
100 km ou nager en pleine mer être
aventuriers c'est un état d'esprit
c'est dans la tête tout le monde peut
faire tout le monde peut devenir un éco
aventurier et donc il suffit juste de
faire preuve de courage de persévérance
être opiniâtre défendent des valeurs
nobles vous monsieur
même les gens qui vont nous regarder sur
internet vous pouvez devenir des éco
aventurier c'est à la portée de tous et
là j'ai oublié mon texte
qu'en fait ce que je fais c'est qu'on
m'a dit d'écrire des trucs c'est les
émotions tout est enfin clair en chacun
de nous sommeille un aventurier voilà
c'est une question fait une question
maintenant j'ai une question pouvez vous
lever la main si vous considérez être
conscient de la dégradation de
l'environnement de ce que j'appelle
notre suicide planétaire d'accord donc
dans cette salle aujourd'hui au tedx on
peut dire que le niveau de conscience
il est élevé c'est vrai je suis sûr
qu'on a tous fait des efforts on a tous
modifié leurs comportements
on fait notre tri sélectif on mange on
essaie de manger bio et local on a tous
fait des efforts mais le problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on est dans une
totale incohérence
par exemple lorsque j'étais au lycée
avec la mèche j'avais 19 ans
j'ai mis en place le tri sélectif super
et je suis revenue quatre ans après et
qu'est-ce qui se passe quatre ans après
il ya plus de tri sélectif donc voilà là
moi je me suis dit au lieu de me battre
dans tous les lycées de france
est ce que je pourrais pas faire une loi
qui rend le tri sélectif obligatoire
dans toutes les écoles parce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut changer le
système il faut qu'on influence nos
politiques parce que la situation est
continue de se dégrader en des tous
conscients alors face à ce constat après
mon diplôme d'école de commerce
au grand malheur de ma mère j'ai refusé
un cdi
j'ai vu la tête de ma mère c'est ans
d'études 8 nov je refuse en cdi et je
vais voir monsieur aventure monsieur
écologie je parle de nicolas hulot
donc je me retrouve avec lui dans son
bureau et on parle et il me dit julien
tuchan
rappaz le monde et moi dans ma tête j la
comment ça changerait pas le monde je le
change d'un peuple et après réflexion je
me suis dit non il a raison je vais pas
changer le monde
vous allez pas changer le monde par
contre vous pouvez changer votre monde
je peux changer nom et mon monde à moi
c'est la bretagne plus belles régions du
monde alors je décide de partir à pied
faire le tour de la bretagne c'est l'
aventure du baiser dash tour ses 68
jours de marche et de course à pied plus
de 1500 km ces deux mille jeunes
j'ai rencontré des jeunes de 5 à 25 ans
et mon objectif c'était de les
sensibiliser à la protection de
l'environnement et surtout qu'ils
imaginent eux leurs propres lois comme
moi j'avais pu imaginer pour le tri
sélectif et sur mon chemin
j'avais je pouvais être un jour avec un
enfants de grande section sur mon genou
à qui j'explique est que les océans
produisait plus de 50% de notre oxygène
et le lendemain à discuter business & co
responsable avec des étudiants de
l'école de commerce
j'en ai profité en même temps pour aller
voir nos amis les députés des députés de
droite
des députés de gauche des députés sans
parti politique est gelé je les ai un
peu secret et sachez vous savez quoi le
31 janvier 2017
on est invité à l'assemblée nationale
pour remettre ses idées de loi au député
et je suis persuadé que l'on va réussir
à créer une commission parlementaire
je suis persuadé qu'un jour on pourra
voir la loi qui rend le tri sélectif
obligatoire dans toutes les écoles
voilà ça c'est moi ce que je fais c'est
ce que je fais mais vous aussi vous
pouvez agir
est ce que vous voulez je vous donne
quatre étapes pour devenir des éco
aventurier hockey la première chose à
faire la première étape c'est de se
renseigner
lisez des articles
regardez documentaire parce que rester
ignorant c'est resté inactif face alain
thorelle à la halle intolérable la
deuxième étape choisir une cible
ça peut être l'école de votre enfant ça
peut être votre entreprise ça peut être
une association ça peut être votre
député ou votre communauté
d'agglomération une fois que vous avez
votre cible troisième étape
vous choisissez une action on a une
multitude vous pouvez très bien défendre
les oiseaux avec la lpo les cétacés avec
sea shepherd travailler avec un
fournisseur d'énergie renouvelable comme
la enercoop travaillé avec un producteur
local et bio ou encore planter des
arbres il ya énormément de choses à
faire mais la quatrième étape c'est la
plus dure c'est l'action et à gandhi cas
une très belle citation je vais vous la
lire soyons le changement que nous
souhaitons voir dans le monde
cette citation elle m'a beaucoup inspiré
mais aujourd'hui j'ai le sentiment qu'il
faut aller plus loin
alors je vais vous propose proposer une
nouvelle citation je vais vous la libye
j'agis concrètement pour créer le
changement que je souhaite voir dans
monde actions merci
[Applaudissements]